there's a picture going viral of Donald
Trump on the campaign Trail signing a
woman's chest
I say chest because it's high up enough
that I don't it's not totally untoward
Trump also clearly has very very strong
autographed discipline because even as
he's signing this woman's chest his hand
is not touching his hand is you can see
a shadow on the lady's white tank top
and she's smiling she's so excited
people all around him in this bar
like their meeting
a celebrity which they are
and I mentioned the photo
to to
return to an objection that some
Republicans are making anti-trump
Republicans are making which is they'll
say yeah Trump's a celebrity but people
shouldn't care about celebrities this
election should not come down to
personality and charm and Charisma and
celebrity dammit that's not what this
election should be about
to which I respond
have you ever seen an election have you
ever
have you ever read about democracy
you ever met any people do you know how
people work with what do you mean it
shouldn't be about celebrity you it is
it is it's Democratic politics man it's
a popularity contest
celebrity matters well it shouldn't
matter okay well the sun shouldn't shine
today okay but it does it's just a fact
of life this is how human beings operate
and it's especially how democracies
operate
so you can whine and cry about it pull
your hair out or you can
accept political reality as it is and
always will be and then try to work from
within it
this is just a fact
having lived in New York and La I've met
a number of celebrities and I've seen
celebrities up close and I have wondered
for many a year
why is it that celebrities have the
effect on people that they do
why is it that the line that got Trump
in the most trouble in 2016 the Access
Hollywood tape
said when you're when you're a celebrity
women let you do it they let you do
whatever you can do whatever you want
women let you do it and everyone was so
offended and clutch their pearls
and I thought
is a vulgar thing to say but it's
especially vulgar and off-putting
because it's so obviously true
yes
celebrity really matters when people are
pulling their hair out they say I just
don't know why Donald Trump is 40 50
points ahead in the polls he shouldn't
be he said some stupid thing which he
did and he did some stupid thing as
president yeah he did he did a number of
them and he he is not as good on this
particular issue as some other candidate
yeah that's probably true too
he's got it man I don't know what to
tell he's just yeah he's a celebrity
Putin called this in 2016. and you might
say Putin's a dirty rotten fella but the
guy knows how to hold on to power and
Vladimir Putin said oh it's very clear
in this GOP Primary Donald Trump is Far
and Away the leader
he just has something about him that
attracts people to him and so if you
want to beat Trump
and I know there are a lot of people who
really hate Trump and they want to beat
him
you need to try to match that and it's
probably not going to happen because the
guy's been a celebrity in his American
original for like 40 years now but
you've got to match that if you're only
a response to that to this guy being a
freaking rock star on the campaign Trail
and signing women's chests if your only
response is well sure but my candidate
he's more competent he's got the
Charisma of competence then you can keep
muttering that to yourself until your
candidates out of the race
and you can shoot the messenger if you
like but that is just a fact in every
single presidential race certainly in my
lifetime and before
maybe ever with maybe the exception
would be Calvin Coolidge
the more charismatic candidate wins
every time
within certain boundaries
within
trying to calculate for certain
eccentricities it happens Trump
obviously in 2016 before that Romney
it's not not Mr Charisma but more so
than many of his competitors
but he lost the general because Obama
was more charismatic than him John
McCain had a little more ethos to him
than some of his competitors
but even controlling for that
Obama much more charismatic than John
McCain
George W bush much more charismatic than
Al Gore and John Kerry Bill Clinton much
more charismatic than Bob Dole Bill
Clinton much more charismatic than
George H.W bush
Ronald Reagan much more charismatic than
the Democrats than Mondale and then
Jimmy Carter and then the entire
Republican field both times
on and on and on
it's the way it works man people
shouldn't be like that okay well people
are so if if you want to run a popular
government of the People by the people
who are the people you've got to account
for the way people work right now go to
helixsleep.com Knowles with everything
going on in the world right now you
could really use a good night's sleep
that is why you need to check out Helix
mattress the Helix lineup offers 20
unique mattresses including the
award-winning Lux collection the newly
released Helix Elite collection a
mattress designed for Big and Tall
sleepers and even a mattress made just
for kids I've had my Helix for years now
I absolutely love it night after night I
sleep like a comfy sweet little babe and
I want the same for you Helix has a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else why do
you want to be in my mattress I'm a
married man and you need your own
mattress so go to helixsleep.com Knowles
take their two-minute sleep quiz to find
the perfect mattress for your body and
sleep type their flexible payment plans
make it so a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20 2-0
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners Helix
sleep.com Knowles use code Helix partner
2020 this is their best offer yet won't
last long with Helix Bittersweet starts
now remember that F-35 that our military
just lost it was a few days ago the
military just misplaced an F-35 airplane
which is hard to lose you know I lose my
car keys sometimes my cigar cutter but
they lost the airplane and
now local news has interviewed someone
who
first noticed the plane coming down
Randolph white retired from his job at
the paper mill in Georgetown 10 years
ago he lives in this house with his wife
in a very rural area of Williamsburg
County he loves living about two miles
away from where he grew up normally it's
pretty quiet but on Sunday afternoon I
was in the uh
and I heard a screeching
saw that between a screech and a whistle
I said what in the world
and I heard boom in my whole house show
white says he didn't realize it was a
plane at the time so he didn't call
anybody
I love America I love America's I love
the American people every time I lose
faith in America it is because of the
elite
degraded decadent perverse
moral idiots who run our country and
every time I have a little faith back in
America it's because of that guy
because of ordinary that guy lives in
the middle of nowhere
he heard this airplane come down didn't
even realize I don't know what that was
and oh here's what it's like ah you know
and he's just explaining it in great
detail
totally without any
um
sense of
facade or any kind of you just
he just calls it like he sees it eager
to do it forthright
totally without any sense of shame or
anything like that
I really love it when people on the
right today Lament The Rise of populism
you know it's all the fancy Republicans
who live in Washington DC and they write
for all of the establishment squishy
papers and they they say you know this
populism is terrible we need to be true
conservatives we need to be in the mold
really my Junior and we need to
wear fancy ties and go to very fun fancy
cocktail parties that is who should be
leading conservatism
I would remind them of a line from
William F Buckley Jr
the so supposed enemy of populism
William F Buckley Jr who said he would
be rather be governed by the first two
thousand people in the Boston phone book
than by The Faculty of Harvard College
because that guy who lives in the middle
of nowhere who seems a little oblivious
about some things he didn't even know a
fighter jet was Landing next to him but
I bet you that guy knows the difference
between a man and a woman I bet that guy
knows some pretty
Elementary stuff that the faculty of
Harvard College and all the fancy people
in Washington DC
have somehow forgotten boy what a great
clip that was now hold on you gotta ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael and
all Show podcast see you next time